do you work out anymore nah man keep
away from that stuff me don't even like
that stuff you know spin class right now
that's tough um we activate to my ego oh
really
yeah oh wow I'm gonna get ripped off
they react that's the thing about like
extreme winners extreme winners that ego
is hard my ego i'ma lose liya Maloof
candidate I lose everything
what if you let go jogging can you go
jogging no I'll do my treadmill working
stuff okay treadmill that's it but but
if I thought the thing that I'm special
if I get a glamour glimmer of that thing
thingy oh yeah you better than know I
saw a video you hit in the bag recently
so a couple years ago you still hit the
bag still throw some balm let's do the
partly for the camera yeah that's what
you're doing but I'm like damn you could
still move you still have it in you
right
oh no it's in your body have to be how
long to do this it feel weird what I was
gonna get to when if you were standing
front that heavy bag and you start
rattling off combinations and people you
start thinking like oh [ __ ] I'm actually
Mike Tyson like I was that guy I am that
guy who went through that I am the
youngest heavyweight champion of all
time I am that guy to destroy Tyrell
Biggs I am that guy that knocked out
Larry Holmes I'm that guy guy I look at
that guy for money give me a platform to
help me forget about that guy Wow yeah
it's it's beautiful that you have that
that mindset it is because most people
who've accomplished as much as you have
they don't want to ever let the past oh
[ __ ] let that go but do you know do you
recognize that that's a beautiful part
of your personality you had one of the
most successful boxing careers ever but
you don't want it you don't want nothing
to do with it you don't want to we want
to acknowledge it exist you wish it went
away in order to arrive to that next
chapter in life you have to forget the
chapter that came before you
yeah and focus on the chapter ahead of
you yes yes that's a great lesson and
from coming from you that lesson I think
is going to hit home with a lot of
people
thing fell yes honey 100% because you
accomplished so much because you were
the youngest heavyweight champion of all
time because you're the baddest man on
the planet is big hero for a lot of
people like me when I was growing up to
see you now say that's then I'm done no
nothing I'm gonna watch it
I don't workout it I'm not I'm not even
a part of that anymore I'm concentrating
my life right now and I'm happy and I
love people you know Joe that's really
crazy but when you think about this
listen you know being that person that
guy that sent me the fake world a couple
of times if anything took so many other
places the pregnant wife fed me play
through that guy's a trip yeah that's a
trick I had you in the underwear holding
a tiger change the trip then what did
you go to the psych ward for it's been
crazy violent probably thought about
hurting myself or something crazy like
that
what do they do when they take you in
the psych ward how do they treat you oh
no same way everybody this is Mike no
but I mean how do they take care of you
what do they do for you
I mean how do they take my [ __ ] pills
that those things are something yeah
throwing you out because I'll be doing a
zombie swag event yeah yeah that is what
they do huh just call me down medically
pharmaceutically well you know what's
going on we can't react to it change
this and then once they got you calmed
down enough to go alright you can go
I don't know I don't think I ever get
calmed down enough time for me to go I
had to go